i mean i feel like v tubing is just
obviously the trends now but i feel like
if anything if you're just if you want
to start off streaming or something or
just you're a new content creator then
just by being a youtuber you're more
likely to get noticed than just by like
being a normal on-camera streamer sure
unfortunately i don't know i don't know
why that is it just
anime bro yeah it's just how it is isn't
it people just want to see anime girls
and boys apparently
they just hate the real people is there
a big
male youtuber i don't think we've seen
any big one though
oh actually the the biggest v tuber in
ninja sanji is a guy
is it really yeah it's this guy called
kuzuha who i think has like
almost 900k subs oh [ __ ] yeah he's
really and he was really interesting as
well because he was actually
scouted by nisanji because he was
originally an individual youtuber
who gained so much of a massive and
dedicated fan base that he got picked up
by ninja sanji and now he's the biggest
ninja sanji streamer and he's
essentially the biggest male streamer i
wonder why i'm not never getting
recommended clips of uh him
because he's very japanese okay
recommended japanese clips all the time
and i'm like i don't watch this but yeah
stop shuffling i mean he's really fun
like i i watched a couple of his streams
and he's super fun to watch
but it's just really interesting how he
managed to
stand on top of a very female
orientation yeah because
that is interesting i don't think we in
english we i don't think there's a big
male v which is weird to think because
most of the big
streamers are male i mean streaming is
like
right now at least a male dominated
market because you got like valkyrie
and pokemane up there in the top 10 but
everyone else i think is male 1 right
or like with v cheapers pretty much i
think ninety percent of
the big v tubers are female right now at
least
yeah definitely i mean like i wonder why
why do you think that it is like just
throwing ideas out there like life
yeah i think literally yeah people want
to watch
cute girls then cute boys right yeah
that's just how it is i think so i don't
i don't know i don't i feel like it's
too easy to say that that's like i don't
know
there's got to be a reason maybe i've
never like i've watched because
sometimes i'll just click the youtuber
tag on twitch and
i'll browse through and you know and i
haven't really seen many guys in there
that i'm like oh yeah
it's not like super naturally
entertaining i don't know right
it's tough because like because what
makes i don't this this might be you
getting into a different topic but what
does make a popular streamer because
yeah maybe you know maybe yeah that's
tough because like because like what
what is
the audience for male streamers it's
still mostly males
or i don't know i feel i i i just i
don't have twitch
it depends on the contents right like i
feel like i have a pretty healthy
balance
yeah right um most you know i don't know
can you even look that up on twitch
[ __ ] if i am you probably can't i know
you can on youtube but like
you can i'll check later yeah we'll
check yeah it is weird now that i think
about it while there are so
few big big up male v cheap as compared
to the females
i don't i don't want to say like the
meme but is it is it maybe the fact that
if you're you know you would just be a
normal male streamer if you were good at
it would like
is there benefits to being a v tuber as
a male over just doing showing your face
if you can
it's it's really strange because like i
feel i i feel
actually like internationally this idea
of like v
tubers has very much been created and
established
through whole life yeah where like you
know but like at the end of the day you
have to realize that whole life is
actually the weirder one because they're
more of like an
idol yeah yeah yeah whereas like ninji
sanjiv youtubers and like
the shojo or like even like the
individual youtubers right they're not
idols they're just streamers i wonder if
it's the case of like
people like it's gonna sound bad but i i
think this is true
yeah i think guys want to watch a guy
who they think is their bro
yeah they think it's their mate they
feel like they can joke with you know
it's their humor
and i think that guys want to watch
girls they they're the ideal of their
girl that they want
yeah yeah i think almost right i agree
with that and i think that works
perfectly with youtubing because you can
give the character you want to play it
but you can also put a nice healthy
injection personality
yeah and i wonder if that doesn't quite
work with guys but then again
i guess that's the question of who
what's the if you're a male v tuber
watch your target demo
are you trying to be the sexy v tuber
because i've seen those guys who are
trying to be the sexy youtuber yeah
cringe internally
and a lot just because i i do the voice
i think that's legit point because i
think like with a lot of male v tubers i
see and it's
kind of like they trying to take the
hololive kind of uh
model yeah and flip it and gender uh and
genderflip it right so i think it works
yeah and i think at the end of the day a
lot of male v uh
male streamers that are big have like an
equal amount of male to female viewers
if not maybe more so male
1 which is really interesting right
because again when i was looking up on
kuzoha the the the top stream of sanji
his audience is 95 percent
like female that makes sense but also in
japan
is normally like they're very much more
willing to buy into that right
but what's really weird is that his
personality does not match that
demographic
his personality is a lot more like gruff
and just like straight to the point he's
really like
foul-mouthed yeah that's popular in
japan though it was popular in japan but
like you would think that the standard
formula to get a female audience right
is like as you said like the very like
like type of guys right but then i i
don't think that it is i think when you
try to be sexy
you're not sexy right yeah and also
especially when you're in an avatar
that's not for me you know maybe because
i'm i'm older right when i see a guy
who's using an anime avatar and he's
doing this like edging voice where
i'm like broke like literally just
imagine a guy in his room in front of
like a dell monitor going oh yeah
oh in france right yeti yeah it's like
to me it's like you know i don't want
that you know you know i'm not [ __ ]
on anyone you know i'm not saying
they're all out there but i have seen
some that have done it and i'm just like
oh for [ __ ] sake
it's hard because i think if you're the
type of personality
that it would need to kill it as a male
v tuber
is also the kind of person who wouldn't
give a [ __ ] about showing their face
yeah i feel i feel like you think so
i feel like if anything unlike being a
female vichy but being a male vichy but
actually
makes it harder for you to get noticed
yeah absolutely definitely yeah yeah
which
yeah i've never really thought about
that until now it's hard cause i'm sure
there's gonna be tons of male youtubers
out there who are like you are totally
wrong
but it's like well i think we come from
a perspective of just general
entertainment and youtube and then live
streaming and
we have these kind of i feel like we've
been doing this for a very long time
yeah and we have kind of we know what
kind of personalities work in certain
areas
so i'm not thinking about it i feel like
when you're in the community you're
almost
too regurgitative of ideas around you
you know you kind of
see you copy everything around you
because that's what people do right you
don't do you don't
try and stand out but yeah yeah i don't
know
it's it's tough it's fascinating because
i love yeah it's so interesting because
that's the thing is that i feel like no
one's really figured it out yet in
english at least
um i'm sure someone's going to comment
be like no but what about this guy
like if they don't know everything
they've done it they
you know if they're killing it really
they'll probably be high up you know
if they're not right now they will be
soon i'll eat my words the fact that we
can't immediately
say a name is i think it's like super
big you know yeah like i'm because
like i i obviously do know male v tubers
yeah yeah
they're saying yeah none of them are
pulling in like the numbers yeah none of
them are pulling in the numbers that
female youtubers are or anywhere
close from what i've seen no no i mean
all the big agencies all the big groups
the main focus is the female of
youtubers and like the male v tubers
there there are like for example hollow
stars but that always seems like
tacked on you know hollow stars doesn't
really pull in that much compared to the
game
really yeah yeah it really does
unfortunately uh for whatever reason
i feel it's because again like that's on
hololive for not promoting holostars as
much as whole
but i i also just think that like they
they don't know
like it's so difficult i think it is
genuinely
very difficult to get the right
personality it's also difficult to like
really nail down like a target
demographic especially if you're a guy
like because you do have so many avenues
unlike
a lot of female v tubers where it's like
your target demographic is very obvious
yeah i also want to say that i don't i'm
not we're not trying to sit here and
argue that it's easy to be a female
youtuber i think it's just like
i don't think the right personality has
like kind of figured it out yet i think
it's the same but it's you know it's
just i think the important thing is that
you can't just take what works for a
female vg but put it in the mail
and expect it to produce the same
results i think it is a very different
field and there is a discussion there
about why
you know it's it's the same with female
streamers as well it's there's a reason
i think that
you know a lot of a lot of the top
streamers right now is
are males you know and that's just the
way things are right now and i think
it's kind of the reverse for v tubers if
anything yeah
um never really thought about it it's
fascinating yeah yeah that's what i mean
this is what the stuff that i i
wake up at middle of the night but this
is right this is why again like i don't
really watch i'm not like an avid
watcher of anyone i just kind of like
watch channels here and there watch like
i'll go on twitch and i'll i've i've
watched a lot of the small youtubers on
twitch i'll just flick between them at
night watch five minutes all right
that's good enough watch five minutes
all right soon enough
just i like seeing what everyone's doing
you know i'm just trying to find
something out there that's really
interesting
yeah and again i think because the scene
is so so young right now like it's got
all of these really interesting problems
that like haven't been figured out yet
whereas youtube and twitch have been
gamified
to death yeah we can probably tell you
who's going to be good and who isn't and
who's going to be able to figure stuff
out you know what i mean like it's it's
uh
it's just again super interesting and i
find it so fascinating and i love
because i'm obsessed with youtube i'm
obsessed with twitch i love all
everything about
content creation and the fact that i get
to experience
something brand new kind of pop up and
get to like watch it unfold is like
the most fun i've had in forever because
i just like youtube
that's why i've just been really
enjoying like kind of watching around
all these different kinds of
youtubers because it's just like it's
just i cuz you know for the longest time
i always just thought
v tubing equals whole life when now i
know that's completely not the case
there are so many variants out there
that are just completely different to a
whole lot
yeah when i find a guy who i think is
small and is about to blow up and
kill it youtuber i'll i'll write it down
i'll let you know yeah i told you
promote it right now i don't think
there's anyone who's kind of got the
right formula that's going to take off
yeah yeah everyone's still trying to
figure out their own thing i think so i
think everyone's kind of scrambling just
get see what
i mean i mean i like feel like the male
v tubing scenes they were waiting for
that first
big creator that everyone's going to
follow because it doesn't work right
they're ninjas
i've not seen enough movement
yeah because like hollow live figured
out the perfect formula for female
youtubers and everyone
like now that they're like write that
down do it again in the more languages
and then it worked and now youtubing is
[ __ ] massive for females and then i
feel like it's going to take that first
massive male creator on the same level
as hololive or like
other big female creators that's gonna
be like okay this is what works everyone
copy this guy
that's literally i mean that's how it
always is right that's this is what
works copy it but then
again like that's why i feel like it's
not really going anywhere right now just
because everyone's just copying everyone
who isn't
seeing massive success yeah so it's
interesting i again like
it's that it's that meme of like the the
artists are giving fifty dollars
i mean that's what youtube and twitch is
like it's just everyone's iterating on
each other and copying and that's how
that's
how it is and that's so there's one
person who's like how about i
yeah yeah yeah someone always has that
one idea
that just changes the system yeah but
then eventually that original person
will just
set a trend and then that trend will
become the norm and then you build on
that trend and you keep building on that
the new system is created